todos tenemos un sueño tal vez unos sean
más grandes que otros hay personas que
se ven con viajar a europa
otras como ver si los mejores tener una
simple deportiva o simplemente ya verse
una carrera mis sueños es llegar a la
cumbre del monte everest
puso en marcha este objetivo hace dos
años cuando empecé a trabajar con el
equipo team pro junto a ellos fui a las
montañas más pequeñitas de ecuador como
el imbabura o el ruco pichincha hasta
las más altas como el cayambe o el
cotopaxi
poco a poco fui subiendo subiendo y mi
perspectiva como montañista creció y me
dio la oportunidad de viajar a perú y
argentina donde me convertí en la mujer
más joven en llegar a la al aconcagua la
montaña más alta de américa
tiene seis mil 962 metros y básicamente
fue una experiencia hermosa que me hizo
crecieron un montón llegamos a mendoza
en un vuelo y después de dos horas
estábamos en penitentes nuestra primera
parada es un pueblito muy chiquito con
una población sumamente escasa aquí
pasamos la noche de refugio cruz de caña
este refugio es muy acogedor y aquí
tuvimos la oportunidad de preparar
nuestro equipo conocerán más montañistas
y al día siguiente salimos de aventura
nos encaminamos hacia la entrada del
parque aconcagua horcones aquí nos
hicieron la entrega de fundas numeradas
nos dieron nuestros permisos y
comenzamos a caminar este tramo fue
sumamente corto llegamos la confluencia
y bueno no tenemos tres horas al llegar
nos asignaron somos gigantescos en los
cuales tenemos que compartir con todos
grupo expedicionario es más unos vascos
y unos brasileños hasta bien la
experiencia estaba muy bien no hicieron
la revisión médica todos pasamos tenían
los permisos para subir el problema fue
cuando cayó la noche la temperatura
comenzó a disminuir rápidamente
estambul a menos tres grados y esto me
hizo pasar una noche horrible junto con
los ronquidos del viento pero después de
una noche adaptación un poco dura tuve
la oportunidad de seguir caminando y
recuperarme rápidamente
después de nueve horas caminando en una
temperatura un poco alta llegamos al
campamento base plaza de mulas este
campamento es como una mini ciudad aquí
todos nos recibieron muy bien nos dieron
de comer pudimos descansar y así este
día tuvimos nuestra segunda revisión
médica tuve algunos problemas porque
básicamente no me gusta mucho el agua y
me deshidraté totalmente no me sentía
muy bien pero resolvimos rápidamente con
pastillas de minerales cafeína vitaminas
y más energizantes
al día siguiente comenzamos a subir más
el desnivel era muy considerable
estábamos a 4300 y teníamos que servir a
5.500 metros el campamento que llevamos
se llama
nido de cóndores aquí la temperatura es
muy baja estamos a menos 20 grados y
básicamente teníamos que armar nuestras
carpas preparar nuestro equipo y en
busca de hielo para después de media
hora conseguir agua entonces para mí
este día fue básicamente el más duro
pero al igual que el siguiente fue
esencial porque tuve la oportunidad de
climate arme de asociarme un poco más
con la naturaleza y estar más preparada
psicológicamente para lo que me venía
al día siguiente al fin llegó el día el
día de hacer cumbre el 17 de febrero no
exportamos las 2 de la mañana y
empezamos a escalar a las 2 y media
junto a nuestros amigos vascos ellos me
apoyaron mucho fuimos campo por campo
paso por paso pasamos colera berlín
independencia a una temperatura en menos
25 grados pero por mala suerte uno de
mis compañeros se descompuso totalmente
tenía principios de hipotermia y ya no
quería caminar el equipo rápidamente se
puso a buscar mantas térmicas un buen
refugio comida bebida más ropa para
ponerse encima y se fue recuperando por
suerte así que es el momento más
esencial para la expedición tenemos que
ver si es que podríamos continuar las
condiciones en unas condiciones muy muy
malas o simplemente bajar y rendirnos
por suerte decidimos no vencernos y
básicamente y seguir subiendo a seguir
subiendo y después de dos horas más de
caminata
llegamos a la cumbre del aconcagua
entonces estábamos muy felices muy
exaltados saltamos llorábamos hacíamos
de todo pero en este momento tuve un
pensamiento un solo pensamiento dije
cuando una persona de verdad desea algo
lo único que hace es no ponerse
limitaciones las limitaciones son las
que no nos permiten cumplir nuestros
sueños las que nos dicen no podemos
tenemos miedo pero en realidad son muy
absurdas en especial la del dinero
porque al decir que no tenemos dinero
estamos diciendo que no somos
suficientes para nuestro sueño ya decir
que no tenemos tiempo estamos diciendo
que no nos merecemos este sueño y el
simple hecho de decir no puedo tengo
miedo es un acto totalmente de cobardía
el aconcagua adicional a las montañas me
enseñaron a superar el frío el miedo el
hambre el dolor y así es como
básicamente aprendí a romper los
esquemas para ser feliz
por un momento todos cierren sus ojos
ahora imagínense sus sueños más grandes
el más importante no sé viajar a la
india volverse médicos tener una mascota
ahora pongan todas sus limitaciones al
frente de ustedes
y cuestiones de por qué no lo estoy
logrando qué debo hacer para lograr
llegar a mi sueño
ahora que todos tienen sus limitaciones
sus preguntas al frente ustedes abran
los ojos
poco a poco van a ir reflexionando sobre
esto van a pensar por qué no lo hago
cuáles son las soluciones y así van a ir
desarrollando reflexionando
y al fin va a tener el sueño en tus
manos
les voy a contar una pequeña fábula para
concluir esto
había una vez un sabio este sabio tenía
a dos jóvenes ellos querían retar lo
querían hacer quedar muy mal entonces el
sabio se para en frente de ellos y los
chicos guardaron un pájaro en sus manos
y le preguntaron sabio que tenemos en
nuestras manos el país sabio la
respuesta era muy obvia entonces los
chicos le hicieron preguntar además de
esto
el pájaro está vivo o muerto
en el momento en que el sabio respondía
que estaba vivo los chicos simplemente
aplastarían al pájaro y lo dejarían caer
pero si decían que el pájaro estaba
muerto lo lanzaría ni lo dejarían ser
libre la respuesta del sabio fue algo
inesperada es simplemente dijo la vida
del pájaro está en sus manos al igual
que la suya así que todo lo que ustedes
hagan toda su vida todas sus decisiones
están en sus manos y sólo ustedes pueden
poner limitaciones así que cuando su
beber es